hi when you say with anne-marie and
we're gonna talk all things beauty and
music today we've obviously seen all
your amazing makeup voices actually it
will be music but with until why your
everyday normal everyday so I try to
look as natural as possible yeah just
try and make it look like a nut oil
makeup no I've got this yes you're
priming moisturizer so did shop that on
and then this is the best thing I've
ever ever had in my life
this is zelans I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it right but I've got
introduced to this from the foundation
through a makeup ice that did my makeup
once she was like look at this stuff
she got my face laughs and they're not
because it looks like you've just put
that cream on but it just makes
everything the same color
I guess that even when I'm just going
out I just shove it on there's this
Gizella is the same thing it's concealer
I just put on the link mine I use these
brushes because they're only feelings
buh-burn Oh Charlotte sorry mascara I
love no products make up forever rolled
up sorry I use that I also have not
gonna finish the spray it just keeps
your makeup on because that when I'm out
on the night I sweat yes and I look the
same when I comment when you come at the
end of a Maya hello hi you when you put
this spray on say I think so that's what
heaven-sent she's not one that stage
love it yeah
I talking about me jump around so much
hey Tosh was days yeah touch the money
into it yeah even if the wind especially
the outside yeah we're not with yeah
you're outside yeah your makeup just
comes
oh oh oh say what sprays the best it's
good and then to finish it well I've got
two things and without my favorite
things I go this is lip gloss glossy lip
gloss they should literally just clear
lip gloss and I used to always love
having a matte lip now they love having
that live but now I'm really internet
has come it's probably my wallet yeah so
I our brows I've gone through different
stages and Lola mattress I've had a
love-hate relationship and have that one
thing and I used to motivate
second distantly yeah that's me I have
that and I was like babe but no so then
I started to grow them back and give
richly got some hair back
now yeah I found this thing this I love
a brow amplifier is just it's like gel
so it's thicker than a year just like
this forum by Brahma scholar sort of
thing and it's the dark brown mist my
natural voice yes so do use this on it
when it's so funny so really I literally
just brush it through and this and this
is the outcome so I'm so happy about
that very pleased to take about half an
hour today
you know they take about two minutes and
then as soon as I'm off stage I'm that
makeup off really straight that's right
way yeah that's how I love not wearing
makeup yeah this is so freeing and
refreshing yeah I do love makeup of
always love makeup and I love the way it
transforms a face and makes you feel
good and awake even when you're tired
when eating I just love taking off as
well so I always think the wrong thing
of wearing just one mascara and those
two comics and it'll just be all black
on the one hand okay because when I go
for big loads and I notice I'll go all
the way forward sunlight yeah yeah I got
it look great and I'll call say anything
on that so yeah that is that was a bad
moment
speaking of tools you've been on so
you've been on yeah didn't so much this
year you've been doing all the festival
of comedy every single and any
opportunity for that yeah yeah how
though house of envy yeah it's a lovely
I mean
started touring with rudimental I
haven't actually stopped yeah we have
literally been on tour that or for about
four years but it is I think is so
important to have that connection with
fans and you know all that
follow your music because if there's a
just note that away of communicate like
people then actually be invited
you can spend all down Twitter and you
can pull out something you can not do
that kind of stuff but I feel like when
I actually see my fans I still just like
more complete every time I see them so I
okay if I were touring the rest of my
life
so what's your favorite song to perform
I feel like every time one of the
singles comes out obviously of the
audience know that one host
so whatever point I'm at whatever scene
was out at that time that's my favorite
ones to perform Utley has everyone seen
it well we love your look and thank you
so much